en un pequeño número de empresas vendidas por más de mil millones de dólares.
No fue diseñado para repartir el capital a través de muchas empresas
que tienen el potencial para triunfar pero por menos, como la mía.
Eso limita el número de ideas financiadas,
el número de empresas que se crean
y quiénes realmente pueden recibir esa financiación para crecer.
Y creo que esto suscita una pregunta difícil:
¿Cuál es nuestro objetivo con el emprendimiento?
Si es crear una pequeña cantidad de empresas de miles de millones de dólares,
sigamos con el capital riesgo, funciona.
Pero si nuestro objetivo es motivar innovaciones
y dar poder a más personas para crear empresas de todos los tamaños,
necesitamos una nueva manera de financiar esas ideas.
Necesitamos un sistema más flexible
que no presione a los emprendedores y los inversores
a un resultado financiero rígido.
Necesitamos democratizar el acceso al capital.
En el verano de 2017 fui a San Francisco
para unirme a una aceleradora tecnológica con otras 30 compañías.
Se suponía que la aceleradora nos enseñaría a recaudar capital riesgo.
Pero cuando llegué,
la comunidad hablaba sobre las ICO u 'Ofertas Iniciales de Moneda'.
Por primera vez, las ICO habían recaudado más dinero para las empresas emergentes
que el capital riesgo.
Era la primera semana del programa.
Viernes de tequila.
Y los fundadores no podían parar de hablar.
"Voy a crear una ICO".
Hasta que un chico dijo:
"¿Y si lo hacemos todos juntos?
Deberíamos crear una ICO que combine el valor de todas nuestras empresas
y reúna dinero como grupo".
A esas alturas, debía hacer la pregunta obvia:
"¿Qué es una ICO?".
Las ICO son una forma que tienen las nuevas empresas de recaudar dinero
emitiendo una moneda digital
sujeta al valor y los servicios que la compañía proporciona.
La moneda actúa de manera similar a las acciones en una empresa,
como en el mercado de valores,
aumentando su valor mientras es negociada en Internet.
Lo más importante, las ICO expandieron los fondos de inversores
desde unos cuantos cientos de empresas de capital riesgo
a millones de personas comunes deseosas de invertir.
Este mercado representaba más dinero.
Representaba más inversores.
Lo que significaba una mayor probabilidad de ser financiado.
Me convencieron.
Aunque la idea de hacerlo juntos todavía sonaba un poco de locos.
Las empresas emergentes compiten entre ellas por inversiones,
se necesitan cientos de reuniones para conseguir un cheque.
Que yo empleara mis 15 valiosos minutos enfrente de un inversor
hablando no solo sobre mi empresa, sino de todas las empresas en el lote
era algo totalmente nuevo.
Pero la idea caló.
Y decidimos cooperar en lugar de competir.
Cada empresa puso un diez por ciento de sus acciones en un fondo común
que después dividimos en criptomonedas negociables
que los inversores podrían comprar y vender.
Seis meses después y cuatro despachos de abogados más tarde...
(Risas)
en enero de 2018, lanzamos la primera ICO
que representaba el valor de cerca de 30 empresas
y una manera completamente nueva de recaudar capital.
Salimos en muchos medios.
Mi titular favorito sobre nosotros fue:
"Inversores de capital riesgo, lean esto y lloren".
(Risas)
Nuestros fondos eran naturalmente más diversos.
Un 20 % de los fundadores eran mujeres.
Un 50 % eran internacionales.
Los inversores estaban más entusiasmados también.
Tenían la posibilidad de conseguir mejores rendimientos,
porque eliminamos las comisiones de intermediarios del capital riesgo.
Y ellos podían tomar su dinero y reinvertirlo,
potencialmente financiando más ideas nuevas de forma más rápida.
Creo que esto crea un ciclo virtuoso del capital
que permite triunfar a muchos más emprendedores.
Porque tener acceso al capital es tener acceso a las oportunidades.
Y solo hemos empezado a imaginar
lo que democratizar el acceso al capital hará.
Nunca me habría imaginado que mi propia búsqueda de financiación
me dirigiría a este escenario,
habiendo ayudado a cerca de 30 empresas a conseguir inversiones.
Imaginen si otros emprendedores intentasen crear nuevas formas de acceder al capital
en lugar de seguir el camino tradicional.
Cambiaría lo que se crea, cambiaría a quién lo crea
y el impacto a largo plazo en la economía.
Y creo que eso es mucho más emocionante
que solo invertir en las próximas nuevas empresas de billones de dólares.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)